alors bill wyman vous avez vécu en
france donc à saint paul de vence
vous aimez la cuisine française ça tombe
bien parce qu'on va vous faire une
interview fromage ou dessert alors
interview fromage ou dessert est ce que
vous préférez
mick jagger et keith richards est un
petit peu comme le celui qui vous
bousculent à l'école la brute de l'école
à elle mais qu'est ce qui est plus sympa
plus compréhensif
si vous avez un problème
j'étais au japon en 1904
mon père est mort pendant que j'étais
là-bas et mecs m'ont beaucoup aidé les
autres n'ont pas pas tellement l'idée
donc c'est quelqu'un de bien quand on en
a vraiment besoin de quelqu'un il est là
c'est pour ça que je vais mieux
est ce que vous préférez votre carrière
solo à vous ou la carrière solo de mick
jagger la mienne j'ai mieux marché cuir
c'est vrai est ce que vous préférez
jouer avec les russes et mine king
devant 3000 personnes à l'olympia ou
avec les rolling stones devant soixante
mille personnes au stade de france
elle aime bien le lympia rien est ce que
vous préférez être le stone silencieux
puisque c'était votre surnom ou le stone
avec une grande bouche et des pantalons
moulants beat y est c'est fait non je
préfère le rappeler fait la version os
silencieuse j'aime pas tout l'adulation
le côté célébrités et compagnie c'est
pas mon truc c'est difficile d'en quand
on est une star
est ce que vous préférez les stones ou
les beatles les jeunes sur scène mais je
préfère c'est les disques des beatles en
studio très juste il a parfaitement
raison
est-ce que la différence est légère mais
c'est ma préférence est ce que vous
préférez lennon mccartney connaissait
tous les deux je m'entendais mieux avec
paul plus sympa plus sympa que john john
était quelquefois difficile est ce que
vous préférez que je vous présente macha
méril clara morgane ou judith godrèche
[Applaudissements]
[Rires]
la pression ça fait seize c'est la
celulle safari parce que après heureuse
satisfaite heureuse de vivre alors que
les deux autres faits tellement
attirante que j'aurais polonais typique
métallique en mariage et et j'aime
j'aime mes enfants je viens si jeune que
mon fils merci bill wyman bill wyman
alors avec eric en tournée en france et
le 26 juin à l'olympia de paris mais là
messieurs et la tournée des stones
évidemment en juillet en partenariat
avec france 2 merci des doigts et mal
merci des racailles et pour être sûr de
ne rien rater de 1h10 tube abonnez vous
y mettez un peu de bleu